bonsoir à tous alors l'idée que je
souhaite partager avec vous ce soir et
que nous sommes tous construits de désir
de travail et que décrypter nous aide à
vivre en accord avec nous mêmes et
souhaite vous montrer que les premiers à
s'y intéresser devraient être les chefs
d'entreprise alors le désir de travail
c'est pas moi ou chouette je vais
travailler ce matin même si ça existe
ainsi si j'en ai rencontré alors joue la
corde c'est pas la majorité
et puis en plus ils osent pas trop le
dire parce que ça pourrait être mal vu
autre petit malentendu écartée
immédiatement le désir de travail n'a
rien à voir avec le désir amoureux ou
sexuelles au travail
lorsqu'à le travail ne fait que lieu de
rencontre le désir de travail c'est le
moteur de notre action qui nous pousse à
réaliser quelque chose dans la vie est
parfois il est malmené là c'est
difficile de se lever le matin pour
aller travailler dans le pire des cas on
peut pas on peut avoir un burn out on
peut avoir une maladie ou même une
tentative de suicide
pour ne pas en arriver là il ya urgence
à regarder de plus près notre désir de
travail alors c'est une théorie qui a
été développé dans les années 90 par
gilles arnaud et roland guinchard et
désire signifie ici un manque à combler
qui nous pousse malgré nous à faire
quelque chose de notre existence et je
dis bien malgré nous parce que quand on
vous pose la question pourquoi on
travaille on répond bas pour gagner
notre vie pour ce venir au besoin dans
notre famille ou même pour partir en
vacances et bien la théorie renverse
totalement cette vision en affirmant que
le travail est une nécessité pour
l'homme et pour notre construction
psychique tout autant que l'amour et ce
besoin irrépressible cette pulsion est à
l'origine de la lune énergie qui nous
pousse à agir chaque jour dans le monde
alors cette conception rejoint
d'ailleurs celle de christophe dejours
un éminent chercheur qui a postulé la
centralité du travail selon laquelle le
travail et constructeurs de notre
psychisme et de notre identité toute
entière pour l'illustrer
imaginez gabriel lien lepénistes et vous
vous demandez mais qu'est ce qui peut
bien pousser gabriel à gravir des
montagnes
alors qui sait parfaitement qui vont qui
vont en baver et bien le désir
pulsionnel de gravir des montagnes se
serait développée chez gabriel depuis
l'enfance au contact de ses barons de
ses éducateurs de son milieu environnant
à l'image de l'épigénétique où les
milieux influence l'expression des gènes
et cette pulsion nommé dead paternel se
développe avec une orientation et une
intensité propre à chacun et puis tout
au long de son ascension
le désir de gabriel serait soutenu par
trois piliers d'abord une vision celle
de s'imaginer arrivant au sommet forme
d'idéal nommé rêve mégalomane et puis
son parcours sera semé d'obstacles froid
fatigue s'est payé des contraintes nommé
fantasme du labeur et puis chaque
obstacle franchi sera une victoire qui
lui redonnera courage c'est le pilier
des réalisations nommé n du désir
alors il est appelé ainsi parce que on
ne supporte pas l'idée que nos
réalisations soit le fruit de nos
pulsions inconscientes et non de notre
volonté consciente et puis notez bien
que le fantasme du labeur est tout aussi
important que les deux autres car on
savoure d'autant plus une réussite que
le niveau de difficulté était élevé
alors vous allez me dire non mais
n'importe quoi
le travail peut pas être un besoin
fondamental essentiel à la construction
psychique de chacun puisque tout le
monde ne travaille pas en fait le
concept de travail dépasse ici largement
celui d'emploi ou de profession il
s'agit de toutes les actions qui
définissent notre rôle dans la société
notre empreinte dans le monde et donc le
désir du travail nous concerne tous sans
exception la personne au foyer qui
éduque ses enfants
le retraité qui apporte ses compétences
à la communauté et même la personne sans
emploi qui mène ses actions de recherche
personne n'échappe aux désirs de travail
c'est une énergie puissante inconsciente
et dans le contenu est le fruit d'une
combinaison bien spécifiques à chacun
tout comme notre adn
elle remet ensuite la société valorise
cette certaine activité plutôt que
d'autres et certains par conformisme
vont s'engager dans une voie qui ne
correspond pas à leur besoin fondamental
développé depuis l'enfance générant à la
londe de la souffrance au travail pour
être épanoui dans ce qu'on fait
apprenons à sortir de ce carcan imposé
par la société pour d'autres la
conjoncture économique les amènera à
accepter un métier qui ne correspond pas
à leurs désirs
et puis en dehors de tous ces cas
d'inadéquation le désir de travail fait
l'objet de nombreux types d'agressions
tels que la qualité de travail empêcher
qu'ils attaquent le rêve mégalomane où
la surcharge de travail qui nuit aux
fantasmes du labeur ou bien encore
l'absence de reconnaissance qui
agressent la haine du désir et ce ne
sont que des exemples alors la
souffrance au travail et le burn out en
particulier font l'objet d'un nombre
croissant de recherche scientifique au
niveau international est depuis 1975
date de la première publication sur le
burn out
on recense 4488 article sur le sujet et
je me suis demandé combien parmi ces
4488 article s'intéresser au burn out
des entrepreneurs je sais pas peut-être
parmi vous y at il des entrepreneurs ou
certains projettent de
devenir en créant une micro entreprise
ou une pme ou bien avez-vous parmi vous
des proches qui sont entrepreneurs et
bien donc la question est de savoir quel
intérêt la recherche porte au beurre
note de cette catégorie de travailleurs
donc j'ai cherché parmi les 4488 article
et j'en ai trouvé 6 donc ça représente
1,3 pour mille des 4488 article sachant
qu'au dernier recensement de l'insee il
y a 4 millions d'entreprises de moins de
250 salariés en france donc à peu près
autant de chefs d'entreprise et ça
représente 13 5% de la population active
donc 1,3 pour mille des recherches et 13
5% de la population active
si on se place maintenant sur un terrain
opérationnel
on s'aperçoit que lors des interventions
d'entreprise sur la souffrance au
travail
le chef d'entreprise d'impliquer en
début de mission il a impliqué lors de
la restitution en fin de mission
mais en général entre les deux rien je
vous renvoie aux travaux thèse de nadège
guide ou alors pourquoi ce désintérêt
pour le vécu du chef d'entreprise
et puis cette omission d'implication
dans les interventions en fait la
réponse peut sembler évidentes parce que
le chef d'entreprise est le décideur
donc lorsque les salariés souffrent au
travail par celui à juste titre qu'il
met en cause et d'ailleurs le code du
travail lui assigne une obligation de
résultat en ce qui concerne la santé
physique et psychique de ses salariés
donc pourquoi s'intéresser à lui puisque
ce sont les salariés qui souffrent et
lui en est le responsable
pourtant comme le souligne olivier
torres l'un des rares chercheurs à
s'intéresser à la question de nombreux
chefs d'entreprise se suicide en france
ça fait pas la une des journaux
si on trouve l'info c'est plutôt dans
les faits divers parce que forcément
dans ce cas là qu'ils dénonçaient bon
une autre raison tient à l'attitude des
dirigeants eux mêmes parce qu'une des
caractéristiques du dirigeant
propriétaire de son entreprise et d'être
totalement identifié à son entreprise
donc lorsqu'elle va mal il le nie il se
bat jusqu'au bout en écartant tous les
saints les signaux d'alerté qui
pourraient se présenter puis d'ailleurs
s'il avoue il perd la confiance de ses
salariés
de ses clients de ses fournisseurs ses
banquiers et donc ils courent à la
faillite
et puis enfin le dirigeant
ce sens privilégié d'être chef
d'entreprise d'ailleurs toute la société
lui dis donc quelle légitimité aurait-il
à ressentir une quelconque souffrance
d'autant que si l'entreprise va mal et
il en est le seul responsable
en conséquence quand il arrive à la
limite
la rupture est brutale qu'elle soit
comportementale avec dans le pire des
cas le suicide qu'elle soit somatiques
avec notamment la fare tu sais la dc où
qu'elles soient mental avec le burn out
alors ses réflexions m'ont amené à des
travaux de recherche au laboratoire
interdit de l'université de lorraine
encouragé par mes directrice joëlle
league et tholot et martin bat alors mon
idée est de renverser ces postures
imposée par la société en affirmant que
le chef d'entreprise au même titre que
tout autre être humain à son propre
désir de travail qu'il a lui aussi ses
rêves mégalomane qu'il subit lui aussi
les contraintes du fantasme du labeur et
que du fait de son identification à
l'entreprise il se glorifie les
réussites me porte aussi comme un phare
dont le poids des échecs
le dirigeant comme tout autre être
humain agit en fonction de son désir de
travail et s'il a décodé il se portera
mieux
il sera plus à l'écouté de celui des
salariés et gagnera en leadership
humaniste alors je suis pas arrivé par
hasard à ses travaux de recherche
parce que avant d'entreprendre des
études en psychologie j'ai travaillé 17
ans dans le monde de l'entreprise comme
auditrice puis directrice financière
alors j'ai pu ressentir les avantages et
inconvénients de chaque niveau
hiérarchique et puis j'ai participé
plusieurs années au comité de direction
en étroite collaboration avec le
directeur général dominic pirson que je
salue d'ailleurs très chaleureusement
et ce n'est pas tout j'ai eu un père
extraordinaire chef d'entreprise une pme
de 200
un conte salariés et que j'ai vu toute
mon enfance et adolescence se battre
avec optimisme pour décrocher nouveaux
marchés et obtenir de nouvelles lignes
de crédit vivent en permanence dans
l'anxiété de ne pouvoir fournir du
travail à tous ses salariés qu'ils
connaissaient tous individuellement et
qui même pour certains étaient des amis
d'enfance
alors pour la petite histoire elle et
alpiniste et il a gravi tous les plus
hauts sommets des alpes
donc vous comprendrez sûrement que il ya
là une des clés de ma dette paternel et
c'est sans doute là jimmy ses
différentes expériences qui m'a permis
de comprendre que le bien-être du chef
d'entreprise est un élément absolument
essentiel au bien être de tous les
salariés
j'ai donc rencontré 24 dirigeants de pme
que j'ai interrogé sur ces thèmes allant
je tiens d'abord à souligner que tous
ont remarqué la rareté des occasions de
parler d'eux mêmes et de leur métier
donc j'ai analysé le contenu leur désir
de travail et donc pour commencer donc
au sujet de leurs dettes paternel donc
cette pulsion fondamentale développé
depuis l'enfance donc l'adéquation ou
non du métier au désir qui va générer
des émotions positives ou négatives et
pour les boules illustré j'ai recueilli
quelques paroles de chef d'entreprise
alors voilà deux cas d'adéquation donc
j'adore ce que je fais c'est d'une
richesse c'est tellement diversifiée ou
bien je suis ravi de ce métier parce
qu'il me rattache à mon père que je n'ai
pas connu
et puis un cas d'inadéquation si je
faisais quelque chose ce serait
certainement moins rémunérateurs mais
beaucoup plus enrichissant
ensuite on a le premier pied donc celui
du rêve mégalomane souvenez vous donc là
on va trouver du côté positif toutes les
ambitions
et puis la recherche d'utilité sociale
et du côté négatif toutes les attentes à
ce rêve
donc voilà un exemple d'ambition le
plaisir au travail et dans le relevé des
défis cela nous enthousiasme de réussir
à faire quelque chose qui était
quasiment mission impossible
et puis exemple d' atteintes portées aux
rêves la pression des banques est
tellement forte
la pression psychologique également
ils vous parlent au téléphone comme si
vous étiez un bandit alors qu'on a un
acte d'engagement signée et qu'on a
commencé à rembourser
le deuxième pilier donc celui du
fantasme du labeur donc ici du côté
positif on va trouver tout ce qui est
valorisation du travail intense les
exigences et puis du côté négatif toutes
les contraintes de temps de management
des conflits et la solitude et c'est un
exemple de valorisation du travail
intense on n'a jamais laissé un client
dans la panade
même s'il fallait travailler de nuit et
pousser notre fournisseurs a travaillé
de nuit
et puis les exemples de contraintes sont
nombreuses en émis quelques uns j'ai eu
aux contrôles fiscaux en trente ans on
peut parler de harcèlement bien je ne me
suis pas toujours payer mon salaire
ou bien alors j'ai mis un avertissement
un salarié suite aux réclamations de son
responsable
ensuite le salarié de m'adresser plus la
parole et le responsable me reprocher
d'avoir dégradé l'ambiance là vous vous
sentez seul
et puis dernier exemple quand j'ai
commencé à voir ses emmerdes
j'étais surpris que ça m'empêche de
dormir et j'ai commencé à prendre des
médicaments
simplement pour me rendormir parce que
j'avais pas de solution ça me mettait
dans une telle excitation que je
m'inventais une solution en mentant à
moi même pour me rendormir
et puis dernier plier celui de la haine
du désir donc là on va trouver toutes
les réussites et les échecs
un exemple de réussite la reconnaissance
en l'alimentent aussi dans sa tête en
disant quand on regarde derrière qu'on a
quand même construit quelque chose et
puis un exemple de difficultés depuis un
an et demi j'ai réglé les problèmes
j'ai repris vie viennent de vie là je
suis après la tempête le mec qui se
réveille sur la plage et qui se dit ça y
est je suis vivant alors mes analyses me
permettent de mesurer l'équilibré
émotionnel de chaque dirigeant sur
chacun des domaines du désir de travail
et parallèlement j'analyse ces données
sous un autre angle ou j'évalue l'
équilibre entre les sources de plaisir
au travail et les sources de souffrance
et les ressources déployées et en
croisant ces deux grilles de lecture
ainsi que certains éléments
sont habitées je travaille à
l'élaboration d'un modèle utile à la
prévention et à la détection des leviers
d'action susceptible de réduire la
souffrance et d'augmenter le plaisir
dans la recherche bien évidemment de la
mise en harmonie du désir de travail
pour le teasing il faudra attendre ma
soutenance de thèse
j'en connais pas encore la date parce
que j'ai encore pas mal d'analysés à
faire là on est dans le domaine de la
pression du temps c'est mon fantasme du
labeur bon en conclusion en conclusion
modifions notre regard sur les chefs
d'entreprise ce sont des hommes et des
femmes qui connaissent des joies et des
peines comme tous les salariés
n'imaginons pas que leur idéal
professionnels se résume à la recherche
de productivité le désir de travail d'un
grand nombre de dirigeants est porté par
des idéaux d'utilité sociale mais leurs
doutes et leurs craintes les fonds bien
trop souvent cédé aux sirènes d'un
conformisme qui les éloigne de ses
valeurs ses dirigeants ont besoin de se
remettre à l'ecoute de même de leur
valeur et de leur désir de travail et
puis chacun d'entre nous entrepreneur ou
non futurs entrepreneurs ou non
interrogeons nous sur notre propre désir
de travail quelle quête poursuivant nous
te souhaitons atteindre au fond de nous
et qui nous dépasse
identifions nos contraintes en
distinguant celle qui nous stimule de
celle qui nous épuise
et puis apprenons à assumer une réussite
comme nos échecs qui font tous partie du
chemin à parcourir car prendre
conscience des différentes composantes
de son désir de travail sait décrypter
ces agissements sait décoder ses
ressentiments et son mal être
et puis s'est donné les moyens de mettre
nos actes et donc notre vie en harmonie
avec notre désir de travail
je vous remercie pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]